welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Avengers in games releasing
more and more deleted scenes on Disney
Plus so if you're looking for a quick
smile hey why not watch them even sadder
black widow death scene and game
featured an alternate Vermeer battle
between Natasha Hawkeye and Thanos and
watching it it's the most fully polished
of the deleted scenes completely effects
music it's as if this thing came right
out of the movie so let's break down
this alternate seen in this episode of
inside Marvel
[Music]
okay the seat begins exactly how it
plays out in the theatrical cut of
endgame
whatever it takes we don't get that
stone billions of people stay tuned I
think yes we both know it's got to be I
guess we do you're starting to think you
mean different people here then some
alternate dialogue Natasha says I am the
logical play I have nothing to lose
Clint responds and I got nothing to live
for so there Natasha says if this works
you know what you get back but then plot
twist green blasts fire at them Clinton
etosha take cover as one of Thanos's cue
ships and some of the necro crafts close
in on them red skull hilariously
disappears in a puff of smoke as if to
say this would have been a consequence
of earlier Thanos scenes and in-game
second act after he and ebony moss can
28 teen nebulas memories to see The
Avengers planning the time ice to figure
out what they were gonna do this led
Thanos to Morag we're 2018 nebula tried
to warn Clinton Natasha about 2014
Thanos Thanos knows the last time we see
Thanos to ship it continues to plow
through space as 2018 MBL is being
tortured by 2014 nebula in 2014 Gamora
which ends with 2014 nebula finding the
Pym particle presented in Sethe a nose
and a theatrical cut this set up 2014
Thanos to follow the Avengers to the
present day but in this deleted scene
Thanos uses this knowledge gained from
nebulas memory to travel to another
stone destination for mere so in the
midst of this battle Clint shouts to
Natasha
not good they're boxing us in Natasha
says do we break out hit him from the
back Clint strategize this okay I take
the left flank you take the right save
your ammo pick your targets on my mark
three two bullets before Clint's can
finish Natasha runs out right down the
middle of no man's land
she painfully takes one blast through
her midsection and then she stumbles in
pain but gets back to her feet she takes
another shot to her chest and then one
really nasty shot from the back through
her shoulder forming an exit wound on
the front side it is so painful to see
those shots go through these characters
because most of the time blasts just
kind of hit them in their core with
their shoulder and it gets absorbed by
like armor or something so that it looks
like they just took a hard punch this
exit
mooned reminds us of that cringey stab
that stark took at the end of the fight
against Thanos on Titan
luckily Stark is a genius engineer with
a magical sealant spray natasha has no
such spray that we know about though she
should all of them should when all the
Avengers have the spray therefore an
exit wound is a tangible sign of their
mortality if your body is being blown
away in chunks there only so many more
chunks that can get blown away all the
while Clint fights on with a sword he
takes a shot to his arm so he drops his
sword but he continues to fight with his
knife his last attackers about to kill
him but he's taken out by one last shot
from Natasha she has dragged herself
across the altar to the edge of this
cliff and now which she looks back at
Clint she sees a familiar specter Thanos
himself marching up just as he was
through the jungles of Wakanda and she
knows that if she does not act now
they'll both be dead and 2014 Thanos
will have one of the stones so with the
ergency raised to maximum threat level
she does what has to be done and throws
herself over the cliff flash of light
and Clint gets caught in that flash
presumably teleporting him from this
mountaintop saving him from Thanos and
bringing him to the pool where he will
wake up with the soul stone in hand but
before I continue this episode was
brought to you by stance stance makes
some of the coolest socks and underwear
in the world we're really excited about
their new line of Star Wars themed socks
and underwear that you can get 10% off
by clicking on the link in the
description of this video
they have socks and underwear with all
your favorite characters Luke Darth
Vader Boba Fett you need to get some
boba boxer briefs say that three times
fast yep here they are nothing shows
appreciation for the Empire like having
grand moff tarkin face on your ankle you
make it they've got sizes for everyone
and some cool box sets that make a great
gift they also have some cool sacks with
images from other properties like Marvel
Disney in the office you can have a
Deadpool on one foot and a
dunder-mifflin on the other if you're
the kind of person likes to wear
mismatched socks so click our special
link in the description to support me
rock stars you get temperance and off
the great Star Wars line of socks and
underwear it's dance may the force be
with your feet the director said that
they cut this scene because even as they
were shooting it they began to feel
something was off and after bringing it
into post-production with editor Jeff
Ford they realized that the scene would
be far more emotional if the conflict
was between Natasha and Clint as opposed
to anonymous minion
that no one has an emotional connection
with and you know what I hear that but I
gotta say see Natasha and Clint on the
same side fighting a bunch of baseless
drones well that's kind of how we've
always seen them in the first Avengers
fighting Chitauri an age of Ultron
fighting though the Ultron drones
this deleted scene doesn't really ring
emotionally hollow for me I kind of love
it see Natasha takes several shots to
and through her chest and shoulders it
hurts
it makes her death a gradual drawn-out
certainty something with honestly a bit
more weight instead of you know what it
was in the movie which I got to say yet
now that i rewatch it feels a bit almost
comedic like a mr. mrs. Smith type
gotcha tango who's it gonna be is gonna
be Natasha
no it's gonna be [ __ ] no that's gonna
leach and it's a dead Avenger and I
don't know which version of this black
widow death do you prefer the version
they end up using in the final cut or
this alternate deleted scene comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on instagram and twitter at EA vas and
follow the new rock stars and subscribe
to new rock stars here on YouTube as we
go deeper and deeper inside Marvel thank
you for joining me
[Music]